anyway here now with more former Florida
attorney general Pam Bondi and Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett
um
because James Comer has said that he got
they did business with dozens of
countries including China Russia Ukraine
Kazakhstan and many others here's the
question I want to know how much money
in business they did with these
countries I want to know how much they
profited I want to know how much Joe got
if he got any and what did he know and
when did he know it because we know he
lied when he said he never talked about
these issues with his son we don't know
an exact number it could be tens of
millions up to a hundred million dollar
you're talking about 31 million from the
Chinese maybe 40 million for the
Russians I know 11 million from Ukraine
but you've got to factor in Romania
Kazakhstan uh Oman and they have one
common denominator these are all the
countries that Barack Obama gave
authority to Vice President Joe Biden to
dictate the policies there so it raises
a very serious question with all of that
money flowing into what I think can
fairly be described as the Biden family
syndicate
is this a president who is now so
compromised has he sold out America to a
foreign adversary
and this is a really good question if
everybody if all of this business took
place does everybody think that the
president may be compromised by these
countries they are are they are not our
friends he's coming no they're not and
you know James Comer has made a very
good point taking just China for example
it appears that Joe Biden has made
decisions that Xi Jinping is very happy
about but Americans aren't from covet to
tick tock uh to the manipulation of U.S
currency to uh you know the use of the
theft of intellectual property the Spy
balloon it was an interesting cartoon
the other day noting that Joe Biden is
underwater on every single issue in
America and asked voters are you happy
with Joe Biden no no no and then a
picture of Xi Jinping the leader of
China yes I'm happy with Joe Biden and I
think that tells the story could be on
that picture Americans need to know
whether our National Security has been
jeopardized by this President Pam I want
to know how much money the Biden family
made from all of these countries and
what did you all know when did he know
it did he profit himself is he
compromised
well Sean you want to know that and 80
percent of Americans want to know it for
good reason because now we know Hunter
Biden is not just some recovering drug
addicted son of a President Hunter
Biden's tentacles are in everything and
everyone connected to Joe Biden and the
emails have shown us they have been for
more than a decade he has a close
relationship with Tony blinken Tony
blinken who coordinated 50 Intel
agencies to say that same laptop that
Hunter Biden was emailing blinking on
was Russian disinformation he Hunter
Biden was instrumental in the election
of Senator Coons we now know he has a
close personal relationship with him who
sits on Judiciary responsible for
investigating Hunter Biden we know as
you said that Hunter Biden made the
initial introduction of McGarvey a union
boss to his father then Vice President
Biden now President Biden who's now
standing up with him for his re-election
so
Russia all roads lead back to Hunter
Biden if he got money from these
countries is that impeachable is that
perhaps even against the law
oh of course it is Sean and that's why
80 percent of Americans care and they're
taking note of this this has been going
on we now know for more than a decade
and Hunter Biden is the Hub and all of
these different people are the spokes
leading back to Joe Biden and now we
know all roads lead to Joe Biden where's
Hunter Biden living what road is he
living on we're here in the White House
Pennsylvania Avenue same question Greg
yeah she's absolutely right Americans
have finally awakened from their deep
Slumber and have wised up to the Biden
family Syndicate 80 percent almost 80
percent now say they're carefully and
closely watching it the key figure is 71
of independent swing voters who make a
difference in the next election say if
this is a serious Scandal indeed they're
right all right Greg Jarrett Pam Bondi
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else